good afternoon bonjour is Canada's great
honor to have President zielinski visit
us here today thank you for coming
we stand here absolutely United in our
defense of democracy and our
condemnation of Vladimir Putin's
unprovoked unjustified and
unconscionable invasion of Ukraine
I've discussed in person today with
President zielinski jiren arteta Tate
we've also had a cabinet meeting we
discussed military needs financial needs
and humanitarian needs for Ukraine today
and for the future at each meeting
Canada was clear as we always are that
we will stand with Ukraine with whatever
it takes for as long as it takes
and today we're backing up this
commitment with further support
we are shifting our approach to provide
multi-year assistance ensuring Ukraine
has the predictable support it needs for
long-term success
as part of this approach I'm announcing
650 million dollars in new military
assistance over the next three years to
supply Ukraine with 50 armored vehicles
including armored medical evacuation
vehicles that will be built by Canadian
workers in London Ontario
[Applause]
we will also contribute pilot and
maintenance instructors to the Joint
Coalition F-16 as well as support for
Leopard 2 tank maintenance
we will also provide Ukraine with 35
drones equipped with high resolution
cameras
and support services as well as light
vehicles and ammunition based on NATO
standards earlier this week Minister
Blair confirmed that Canada will provide
a financial contribution
to the Consortium led by the United
Kingdom to deliver
defense air defense equipment to Ukraine
Ukraine's resilience to date has been
remarkable
but their economy continues to need
support so that it can withstand this
Invasion so that government has the
resources it needs to continue to
provide services to its people
so that it has the long-term certainty
to plan and coordinate assistance
effectively and so that when Ukraine is
Victorious it will continue to be a
strong and prosperous country
that is why I am today confirming that
we will again provide substantial
macroeconomic support to Ukraine in the
2024 fiscal year
we've just signed a free trade agreement
that supports the economic development
of Ukraine and provides Canadian
companies
privileged access
later today
to meet with leaders from the business
world we will discuss how the private
sector can support efforts by Ukraine
and already participate in rebuilding
the country Meanwhile we're continuing
to impose costs on Russia and ensuring
that those responsible for this illegal
unjustifiable Invasion do not benefit
from it
first Canada and Ukraine have agreed to
engage with G7 Partners to establish a
working group of eminent persons who
will provide advice on the seizure and
forfeiture of Russian assets including
of the Russian Central Bank
second
[Applause]
we're adding another 63 Russian
individuals and entities to our
sanctions list including those complicit
in the kidnapping of children and the
spreading of disinformation
all of Ukrainian Society needs support
to support Civil Society we will assess
we will assist local ngos and assist the
Ukrainian parliament in improving its
cyber resilience
to assist communities we are also
supporting the rebuilding of local
infrastructure and we are helping
farmers who have been disturbed by
Putin's actions to preserve the memory
of victims of the holodomor Canada is
prepared to contribute to the holodomor
museum in Ukraine once appropriate
arrangements are in place and to help
all affected ukrainians we're providing
funding to make mental health support
more available
because the toll this is taking on the
well-being of citizens even those not on
the front lines
can never be understated
of course
it will not be possible to rebuild
before peace is re-established as I said
in Parliament today
and as I said at the UN Security Council
this week
this piece
must not be a false peace based on
compromises that reward the aggressor
we must have lasting peace
respecting the U.N Charter
respecting international law
to restore
territorial Integrity to Ukraine it was
powerful
to hear president zielinski speak to
parliamentarians today
and this evening he will again speak
this time directly to Canadians
including Ukrainian Canadians
at an event in Toronto
over 1.4 million Canadians have
Ukrainian roots
but this war has made
all of us as Canadians connected to
Ukraine this country has seen an
incredible outpouring of support that is
unique in the way that it comes from all
corners of society
from the diaspora
from different orders of government
from different charities
and from across the Canadian public
because your fight
is our fight
these new announcements we have made
build on nearly nine billion dollars of
support since this full-scale Invasion
began
built on years of support through
initiatives like operation unifier that
has trained up tens of thousands of
Ukrainian Fighters
and Alicia
2700 individuals or entities that we
have sanctioned since Putin illegally
occupied Crimea in 2014.
Canada's support for Ukraine is
unequivocal and always will be
and Vladimir I have to say that the
steadfastedness and the strength of your
leadership of your compassion and of how
you have inspired not just ukrainians
not just Canadians but people all around
the world to look at what they can do
concretely to
what is right continue to stand as is an
inspiration to us all including to me my
dear friend so thank you very much we
will continue to stand with you as long
as it takes
[Applause]
I thank you Justine
my dear friend
prime minister
fellow guests
members of government in journalists
today I together with my
first lady of Ukraine together with my
team have arrived to Canada in order to
personally say thank you for all this
support provided to the ukrainians
at times of war in a different other
times the people of Ukraine are
receiving only respect from the
Canadians only they desire to help only
the trust so please know that we are
greatly appreciating this support and
Ukraine was shall always remember that
and when we will gain Victory and we
will be victorious you have to know this
is going to be our common Victory with
the Canada with all the partners with
all the friends with the whole free
world that is free because there is
Nations that are protecting the freedom
and life with dedication it was an honor
for me to address the parliament of
Canada
I thank you this is already my second
statement but today it was offline like
face to face and it's we are very
grateful that all the parties all the
parliament are supporting us we had also
a very fruitful meeting with the general
governor of Canada and surely we have it
a very fruitful negotiations with Justin
I'm very grateful to you and
the Prime Minister together with his
strong team has been always supporting
us and assisting us we have a very good
agreements our defensive cooperation
since the start of the full-scale
aggression was very effective Canada has
provided as her assistance for over 8
billion uh Canadian dollars there's
houses armored vehicles ammunition
Firearms Canada has trained over 40
Southern of Ukrainian soldiers under the
framework of the unifier operation I'd
like to specially outline Canadian
leadership in the humanitarian
demining this is very important for
ukrainians because around the third part
of the territory of Ukraine are
contaminated with the unexploded
Ordnance these are the leftovers of the
Russian shelling this is an enormous
amount of work
that we would need to do in order to
clean our territory from the from the
mines but I'm confident that together
with the Canadian support we shall be
implementing and fulfilling those tasks
we highly appreciate the decision of the
Canada to join the training program for
F-16 Pilots I thank you Justin we have
discussed in a detailed manner on the
air defense I've expressed gratitude for
the procurement of additional missiles
for air defense systems this is a very
uh timely decision as a lot of missiles
Iranian drones are being used against
their civilian infrastructure against
our people today we have received a new
package of
Defense support this was already
mentioned by adjusting the armored
vehicles as well as armored medical
evacuation Vehicles this is something
that we highly need for our wounded
Heroes we have discussed our cooperation
in the field of military industry and
the joint production of the weapon we
were expecting for the participation of
the Ukrainian companies in the first uh
Forum of Defense industries that will be
held in Ukraine very soon then we've
reinforced our economic cooperation we
have signed the renewed or updated Free
Trade Agreement this will serve a
foundation for the Innovation Canada is
one of our largest donors and very
grateful for the decision to continue to
support Ukraine what's important is
ready it continues with the First with
further sanctions pass through against
the aggressor so that uh the aggressor
would not be able to fund the aggression
then we have discussed different aspects
of the peace formula and that includes
Justice and the accountability for the
damages caused by the Russia to Ukraine
as the result of this aggression I'm
grateful to Canada for supporting our
work on the organization of the Global
Peace formula Summit and I'm very
grateful for the leadership uh to work
on the security guarantees for Ukraine
until the joining with NATO our teams
are working on a bilateral documents of
security guarantees one other very
important thing the Ukrainian community
in Canada I'm very grateful to all of
its members I'm very grateful to that
the ukrainians in Canada Ukrainian
culture in Canada are always at the same
level together with other cultures and
other languages of other minorities the
equality and respect to the other
communities is an important
characteristic of your country this will
always stay like that I'm very grateful
let us have the victory as soon as
possible that I have our common victory
rain
[Applause]
it will take you from the Canadian media
to questions from the Ukrainian medium
we will take two questions from Canadian
media two questions from the Ukrainian
media we will begin with
Mr Prime Minister upon the president I
got a question for both of you you will
be likely agree that the most
significant way Canada can help Ukraine
is to guarantee security as long as the
war continues and to help in achieving a
just Peace So Mr Trudeau do you already
know which security guarantees uh Canada
will be able to provide to Ukraine and
for the peace plan which steps of
President zelinski peace formula does
Canada supports uh president
Mr President considering the level of
cooperation and your personal
cooperation with the Prime Minister what
are your expectations of the support of
Canada to Europe is formula as well as
the security guarantees for Ukraine
thank you very much first of all on the
security guarantees Canada is stepping
up today to announce the kind of
multi-year support that is a concrete
embodiment of what we've been saying
since the very beginning which is that
Canada will stand with Ukraine with
whatever it takes for as long as it
takes it says not just because Canada
and Ukraine are historical friends that
we have deep people-to-people ties or
even that you know Vladimir and I are
great friends in person
it's because this is the right thing to
do
Ukraine is standing up and fighting and
dying for the rules-based order that
protects all of us
it is in Canadians interests to ensure
that Ukraine wins this war that Russia
does not win this war
the impacts that we're feeling whether
it's on food and grocery prices or fuel
prices
have been deeply negatively impacted for
families from coast to coast to coast
and indeed around the world by this war
and that's why we will continue to stand
with Ukraine with whatever it takes for
as long as it takes when it comes to the
peace process we fully support the
priest peace process and the biggest
challenge we have is uh is yeah
understanding that we can't pick all of
them to lead on we have to pick just a
few uh and we're in conversations with
that
um one of the ones that we are very much
looking at is how we can support around
displaced persons and the Abduction of
children that's something that Canada
has obviously when it comes to migration
and welcoming 175 000 5 000 ukrainians
uh and Counting an example of of a place
where we can we can show leadership on
this issue around the world
and thank you for your question
good afternoon first as for this
security guarantees this is a very
strong bilateral uh that was mentioned
at the Ville news Summit at the G7
countries Summit and there will be a
separate bilateral document with every
country on security guarantees we
clearly understand what those guarantees
are because we are
at War we are at tests so this is a
security guarantees both military and
humanitarian guarantees the
reinforcement of the Ukrainian armed
forces in order not to have any other
attempt of any aggression by any other
aggressor now we're talking about Russia
we are talking about the strong
protection in the air at Etsy we know
all the areas that are usually used by
the aggressor that is the energy sector
which is also very important and it's
combined with the reinforcement of air
defense
surely you are perfectly aware of this
the protection of the energy the
protection of the infrastructure of
critical infrastructure there's many
other aspects then there are a number of
preventive sanctions a list of sanctions
that shall be imposed at uh against
certain aggressor in case of the
aggression
we the teams are working and the reason
uh I've said about the different
agreements because you know that there
are countries who can provide weapons
then there is there are countries who
are ready to talk about the humanitarian
assistance simply because they don't
have a powerful armed forces or the
ability to produce Weaponry that is why
there will be separate agreements with a
separate country that is why the G7
countries their top priority because
these are the powerful countries that
are able to provide the strong security
guarantees as for the peace formula the
most important task
is to make sure that all the peaceful
negotiations would remain focused
so we are the victim and Russia is the
aggressor we are under attack the war is
in Ukraine that is why it is absolutely
fair that the format of the peace
formula was offered by Ukraine a country
which is defending its independence and
fighting for its life we have suggested
uh a number of aspects and we're
currently working on the organization of
the inauguration Summit and a big task
for us is uh to make sure there will be
as many countries from different
continents as possible engaged into the
formula because that would mean that
Russia and its aggression is left
were on itself and there is a political
isolation of the Russian Federation this
is very important then on the basis of
the first inauguration Summit our
security advisors and diplomatic
Representatives will start working at
different platforms on each point of the
peace formula separately so there are
countries who will be joining all the
points there are countries who are ready
to support only certain points and that
is absolutely normal for us it is
important to have as many countries as
possible engaged then all of these
points will be submitted to the leaders
of the Nations
Ki
did President bison Ukraine long-range
Army tactical missile systems and for
both leaders How concerned are you about
divisions in U.S Congress NATO allies
like Poland polling military support for
Ukraine and getting Ukraine the
supported needs prime minister in French
and English please and what can Canada
do in that respect with allies
excuse me can can you repeat the second
part of your question the first was
about the weapon correct and the United
States and the second part can you
repeat this sure no problem how
concerned are you with divisions in U.S
Congress with some recent divisions
amongst NATO allies like Poland in terms
of getting Ukraine the military aid it
needs as quickly as it needs and I'm
wondering if you think Canada can play a
role to encourage allies
thank you
we are grateful to the United States
and with all due respect to all of our
allies United States provide the largest
share of assistance and the assistance
that our soldiers on the battlefield on
the front line really need at this
moment so we are discussing all the
different types of uh weapons
and artillery
shells with the caliber of 155
millimeters than air defense systems
therefore we have a comprehensive
discussion and the work with the United
States at different levels we have
cooperation at security at the level of
security advisors at the level of
Ministers of defense and at our level
that's a separate bilateral kind of
relations at a level of Precedence I
believe that the majority of what has
been discussed yesterday with President
Biden I think will be able to re teach
the agreements yes it is a matter of
time not everything depends on Ukraine
there's different processes I have to
say frankly the sooner the last people
will lose this is the fact as for the
assistance to Ukraine we are working
with all the states I understand that
Russia on its side is spreading
disinformation and spreading its
narratives all around the place it works
with the societies it trying to
influence the politicians the public
institutions with different political
parties different angios with many from
different countries of the world they're
working they're working very hard they
are investing billions into that this is
a fact that is in order to divide the
Europe divide the United States and
divide the whole world they have a
significant influence they keep
influencing the African continent they
constantly working with Latin American
countries
while they're spending a lot of efforts
a lot of attention a lot of money for
that it's hard to tackle that that is
why the long war that is why they're
working long on that our task as Ukraine
and this is something that I would like
to address to our Canadian friends and
to you journalists you are the weapons
capable of uniting the society and just
as today we've talked with Justin about
this I really want the prime minister to
help us with that I'm confident he's
can't that he can do that because Canada
has powerful relationship with many
countries of the world we cannot let
Russia divide the opinions in the world
there doing that now if the opinions
will be divided if the if the unity will
be broken this powerful Unity that we've
managed to acquire in the beginning of
the war then there could be no support
for Ukraine that's a fact
as you all know Canada has been very
very active in supporting crane directly
with humanitarian support Military
Support financial and economic support
but we've also been very very active on
the world stage Canada is one of the
most interconnected countries in the
world members of the G7 of the G20
the Commonwealth the organization of
American states
of Apec of so many different gatherings
in which we have been unequivocal
in standing not just up for Ukraine and
encouraging others to stand alongside us
but in ensuring that people understood
that this is not just a matter of a war
in Eastern Europe that might not matter
to people across the global South
but it is a contract that does matter
around the world yes because of food
prices because of energy prices because
of the geopolitical instability that
Russia is creating with its illegal
invasion
but also because the matter of
sovereignty
of territorial integrity
of the rule of law must and does matter
to all countries around the world
so Canada has been incredibly active
alongside Ukraine in all the moments
where Vladimir has appeared at various
Summits to stand up for Ukraine and
stand up for the rule of law but also in
Summits like the most recent G20 where
Vladimir wasn't able to be joining us
Canada spoke clearly and strongly and
worked to convene Partners we will do
this because we are a country that
always stands up against the rule of law
and as Vladimir said
the propaganda the misinformation the
disinformation that Russia is
aggressively spreading
throughout our democracies is something
that we have to counter with facts with
values
and with the kind of strength and
solidarity that will see us through
these difficult times
Canada has always been there for Ukraine
at the bilateral level we're there with
military assistance humanitarian
assistance financial assistance
but we are also there
on the world stage
standing up unequivocally
for Ukraine sovereignty but also the
principles of sovereignty and
territorial Integrity
that are essential
functioning of all of our countries we
have and we will continue to be there to
underline how much this conflict impacts
us all
we must all stand
by the U.N Charter
Law and Order
and stability and prosperity
that the world has known for 75 years
that has been broken by Russia and its
illegal actions Canada will continue to
be there for Ukraine and for the rule of
law
thank you next question maximum
okay prime minister Mr President thank
you for taking the questions so I also
have a question for both of you so for
the Prime Minister are you concerned
since the reason to published report by
the American Department of the treasury
ranks Canada eighths in the world
expected for instance invasions by local
companies regime be strengthened in
order to deter this type of activity
and for the president next
recently some of the western Partners
mentioned the need for running elections
in Ukraine in accordance to the terms
and the Constitution prohibits the
elections during the martial law period
to have any pressure from Canada on the
need to have elections next year and
whether the Canada is ready to support
that
countries that has stepped up the
quickest and the most comprehensively on
sanctioning those responsible for this
illegal War Putin and all his cronies
and the people who've profited from it
whether they be in Russia or Belarus or
elsewhere we will continue we've
sanctioned about 2 700 people and
entities and
we will continue to we are constantly
working to strengthen to coordinate with
our allies to make sure that these
sanctions have the right impact on the
people responsible for this war while
ensuring that they are not harming
people in the global South who are
facing food insecurity or energy
insecurity that is the role that Canada
continues to play to highlight that
Russia is and is responsible alone
for the food and energy crisis that so
many people around the world are facing
right now
okay Canada
is one of the strongest countries in
terms of sanctions against the Russians
and others who are involved who are
profiting from this illegal War who will
of course continue to work with our
allies with our partners to ensure that
these sanctions
as hard as possible
while ensuring that we are not hurting
the most vulnerable around the world who
are suffering because of this war by
Russia
especially
in terms of the price of food and energy
thank you for the question first Canada
is not pressing
and uh
we have a
warm relationship really you should not
press you can raise the issue but not
press
but
uh
secondly the team of the Prime Minister
we haven't raised the issue of Elections
because it's not topical issue
considering the security aspects you
were right to mention that the law
prohibits uh the elections at the time
of the martial law period but I'm ready
but the security is a very complicated
aspect of running the elections the
first complexity is to have the
elections in a democratic and
transparent matter for that we need
independent observers from different
countries of the world
how it's usually done in Ukraine in a
democratic and transparent manner just
as it was during the previous elections
now the second question how to
give a chance to vote for the people
located on the temporary occupied
territories I'm not talking about the
the
territories occupied in 2014. I'm
talking about those territories that
were occupied after the 24th of February
now this is a complicated matter we need
to think of that then third
a lot of ukrainians not hundred
thousands but millions of ukrainians are
abroad and how to organize the voting
process for them it's a difficult matter
from the standpoint of infrastructure
and at this point there is no answer
with that as for the funding
we are currently saying that in Ukraine
which is absolutely Fair the society is
responding harsh whenever the parliament
or the government is willing to you know
to allocate money to a certain direction
which is different from weapons I mean
the society is not ready to support that
and the society is in fact is absolutely
against that because we are at War and
everyone thinks you know
what sort of elections are you kind of
thinking about but this topic is raised
we need to get ready to be ready for
this topic and the last but not the
least I think
the largest complication
it's it's the military because we have a
million of soldiers and I mean how
they're going to vote while in the
trenches
how they will be able to visit the
polling stations close to the front line
so everything should be organized in the
bomb shelters you know we know Russia
because they will simply open for it all
the people who would be coming to the
elections and I mean will you be able to
find The Observers ready to go to the
trenches and to make sure there is a
transparent elections unfortunately we
don't have an online voting in Ukraine
now speaking of military you have to
understand this is the largest kind of
unfairness because the people who are
protecting the rights and Liberties of
the citizens will have a chance to vote
I mean that's that's nonsense
therefore we have to think about this we
have to if everything will will succeed
then we can do the the elections
social uh good on you for putting the
thingy because I'm going to ask the
question in French
skills in the parliament but a bit more
complex in here
um Mr Trudeau Canada has announced
150 additional 650 additional million
dollars that's nine billion dollars
since the beginning of the war we've
seen resistance at Congress in the U.S
yesterday
do you feel
that there's a little bit of fatigue
setting in that it's become more
difficult to convince people to continue
to stand by Ukraine and Mr zelenski
could I hear you on that as well and
while I'm at it Mr Trudeau on India
you asked India to collaborate in the
investigation they said they haven't
received anything yet
when will you provide the evidence to
them thank you
merci thank you first we all understand
that this is an economically difficult
time Canadians
I'll start over we all know that we are
experiencing economically difficult
times around the world crises have
multiplied
following the pandemic
the war in Ukraine and Russia's illegal
Invasion which has destabilized prices
the impact of climate change we are
facing very difficult times
that is why Canada
like other countries
is there to help to help our people to
help people get through these difficult
times but we understand that Global
challenges
have
Global Solutions
so that is why we are part of a group
standing firm against Russia to defend
Ukraine
we know
the destabilization of the global order
that would happen if Russia succeeded
uh
in overthrowing
the rules-based order would have a
profound economic impact for people that
is why we are doing both things at the
same time
we are there for Ukraine because of the
it is the right thing to do for
ukrainians but also because it is the
right thing to do for Canadians
and we are there for Canadians at the
same time I understand that in all
countries around the world
more and more complex budgetary
situations
that is why the
we are looking at ways to directly help
Ukraine
with money from you from Russia
the Central Bank of Russia
has two to three hundred billion dollars
in assets mainly in Europe and the
United States
but today we've announced a working
group to look at how we can use that
money
put it to work to help ukrainians who
are suffering because of Russia
so we will continue to be Innovative to
be present in standing up for Ukraine
and we will also be Resolute that it is
in the economic interest
of Canada and even Canadians to continue
to be present
everything it takes for as long as it
takes
so that Russia is not Victorious
okay we know this is a difficult time
right now for all Canadians for people
around the world
the impact of climate change and extreme
weather events The Hangover from the
pandemic
and indeed the direct impact on food
prices and energy prices linked to
Russia's illegal invasion of Ukraine
means that people are having a hard time
and that's why we're stepping up as a
country to support our citizens but
that's also why we recognize that Global
problems of global Solutions
and we will continue to be there to
ensure that Russia does not emerge
Victorious
because the impact a Russian Victory
which isn't just a victory over Ukraine
but would be an overthrowing of the
rules-based order that has led to
unprecedented prosperity and opportunity
for people around the world over 75
years
if Russia were to win Canadians in their
daily lives
in their grocery bills
in the opportunities they have for the
future would be directly impacted
so we will continue to be there with as
much as it takes for as long as it takes
but that's also
this financial context is why we are
looking very carefully
at how we can ensure that Russia itself
is paying for the devastation they're
causing in Ukraine
we've announced today a working group
will look to create
to see if things like Russian Central
Bank assets which total two or three
hundred billion dollars in Europe and in
the United States primarily
could be set to actually support Ukraine
in this fight and indeed help over the
long term to restore the prosperity and
peace for the people of Ukraine
thank you for the question
I believe the prime minister
has
covered
all the details for your question I
don't think I will be able to compliment
his answer
but some of the aspects very briefly
I believe that
you're supporting either Ukraine or
Russia there's no mediators in this war
by
weakening the support of Ukraine urine
forcing Russia and
our
and what can you expect of it I think
the history
and the historic books and the witnesses
has gave all the answers necessary
that's it if someone wants to take a
risk okay
now weaken the support to ukrainians but
should I be absolutely Frank
in case of Freedom democracy and human
rights you need to fight for those
that's a fact and money yes we are
grateful to all the countries have been
helping us with weapons with money and
who continues to do so but this is not
the not the most important the most
important is that the most the largest
prize this is something that Ukraine is
paid because we are paying with the
lives of our people so we are grateful
for your support thank you
I was thinking I missed the part of the
question on India
I just want to Simply say that we've
shared those allegations those credible
allegations with India for weeks
we are working with our partners
and what we are asking is for India to
commit constructively with Canada
to establish
fit the facts on this situation we're
there to work with them
and we have been for weeks now
in regards to India
Canada has shared the credible
allegations
that I talked about on Monday with India
we did that many weeks ago
and we are there to work constructively
with India and we hope that they engage
with us so that we can get to the bottom
of this very serious matter
thank you this concludes our conference